wenn ich beschwerden müsste sommer jetzt
so großer motor auf schweizer mentalität
ja dann würde sagen mir erscheint als
ideale kombination von zwei charakter
merkmalen von denen jeder für sich und
erträglich wäre miteinander aber dass
ein fast menschlicher sozialer gibt
nämlich die kombination von biebers hin
und anarchismus flughafen zürich das tod
zu schweiz dann und wann fällt einer
über das land herein heute robert
menasse er tut es mit charme oder eben
österreichisch mit schnee er besucht
steht von 25 literatur kritiker und
zügig robert menasse ist schriftsteller
der gefragte beobachter der
zeitgeschichte kommt dass wir zwei vor
seinem freund eine rebellische schweiz
eine etwas verrückte schweiz zeigen wie
sie der österreicher menasse uns rand
ein paar wochen vor den eidgenössischen
wahlen davon haben diese film
[Musik]
das herz der schweiz ist aus granit
vorbei am großen und kleinen mieten geht
es hinauf zum ganz großen mythos unser
österreichischer gastwirt erst einmal
auf den grob tat geführt
[Musik]
stefan zweifel zeigt seinem besuch eine
bis vor kurzem streng geheime
militärische anlage quasi hier kommt man
nicht raus und nicht wenn es ist
vielleicht wie das schweizer recht nur
eine art kriegs ab
[Applaus]
die gotthard festung war militärische
sperrzone eben das sagenumwobene rego
heute hat sich ein fenster das hotel
kloster eingebunkert stefan zweifel
führt robert menasse in die festung
die punkte werden von der armee seit ein
paar jahren nicht mehr gebraucht aber
offenbar ist und schweizern die einigung
im leib und seele übergegangen
ein geschäftstüchtiger eidgenosse hat
hier ein luxushotel eröffnet
für 9 millionen franken wohl eher ein
gläserner rückzugsort für seminar
besuchen und reiche touristen eingebaut
außerdem fasziniert an der ganzen
geschichte ist wie historisch über lange
zeit gewachsene selbstverständnis das
zum globalen und internationalen
klischee über die schweiz geworden ist
nämlich die bedingungslose
wehrhaftigkeit und die radikale
bereitschaft selbstverteidigung wie eine
werde die schweiz eine wagenburg in der
mitte ist der goldschatz und rundherum
ist verteidigung
das ist ein über lange zeit gewachsenes
globales kirche über die schweiz
die idee eigentlich dieser anlage dieses
luxus hotels in diesem ritt wie drin ist
dermaßen zur iaa dass man sie in der
beschreibung gar nicht übertreffen kann
jetzt wenn man drin steht meine
friedrich dürrenmatt der ja im zweiten
weltkrieg daran verzweifelt dass er
irgendwo in der westschweiz eigentlich
nur schuhe putzen konnte und gar nichts
unternehmen konnte und er vorhin eine
leichte faszination auch für hitler
entwickelt hatte und danach hat zu einem
der größten kritiker genau dieser abbey
vorstellung und diese wehrhaftigkeit
wurde
der hat dann im winterkrieg in gebet ja
sich das ausgemalt seine riesiger
stollen nach dem dritten weltkrieg war
ein übriggebliebener soldaten mit seinen
prothesen in die wände seine geschichte
ein schreibt über hunderte von metern
und dann hat er auch dann diese diese
stollen wände mit pornografischen
bildern zugepflastert dieser soldat also
auch dürrenmatt der ja mit der metapher
dass wir schweizer umkehr am liebsten in
einem gefängnis leben und die schweiz
ein gefängnis ist und wir uns lieber
einsperren weil wir uns in diesem
eingesperrten so wohlfühlen weil wir
dann immerhin die eigenen gefängnis
regeln bestimmen können hat natürlich
auch diese diese diese erotische
komponente dieses eingesperrtseins in
diesem in diesem verrückten in dieser
verrückten stoll und fantasie
winterkrieg gebiet eigentlich nicht den
stein aber in worte gemeißelt
schon bald wird klar dass menasse und
zwei wo sich in ihren dicken büchern
kürzer fassen können als vor kamera und
mikrofon
[Musik]
die zwei streifen durch das graniten
herz der schweiz
der hotelier verweist stolz auf seinen
seminarraum für 120 personen banker
rückversicherer und wohl auch solche die
militärdienst nicht genug bekommen haben
lassen sich hier für eine woche ein
sperren ohne nadel oder e mail
auch wenn ihre gedanken akrobatik auf
einer oberen etage stattfindet rütteln
die beiden literaten ganz schön am einen
patriotischen fundament
[Musik]
aus der gotthard festung zu stellen
schlucht das herz der schweiz ist auch
ein wasserschloss in alle europäischen
richtungen fließt unser einziger
bodenschatz
und verteufelt brücke durch schießt die
reuss und gleich daneben schießt die
schweizer armee überhaupt ist ihr ein
kriegerischer boden da steht das denkmal
für general so ruf diese paar
quadratmeter sind russische bogen mitten
im herzen der schweiz
wir stehen hier ja alle teufelsschlucht
dosen sagen
dort oben den bergen wo die alten
eidgenossen im um 1300 umgestellt haben
auf die wirtschaft und angefangen habe
neben fleisch zu machen und asse und den
konnten uns sehr gut verkaufen intel
runter wo das getreide im überfluss
vorhanden war wegen der fest
sie haben also auch hier schon ganz früh
aus der not eine tugend gemacht und ein
geschäftsmodell und wir sind im rausch
vom wasser und das ist ein teufel
schläft oder es gibt ja auch die
teuflische idee dass man jetzt auf den
wasservorräten ein schweizer geschäft
macht und es wird ist skandalös was
heißen
die bewegungen reichtum dieser länder
halten zum beispiel europa und ich weiß
nicht ob sie das wissen wasser ist das
jüngste menschenrechts der europäische
union hat in der europäischen
menschenrechts erklärung das recht jedes
menschen auf sauberes wasser als
menschenrecht festgeschrieben
und da die schweiz nicht mitglied der
europäischen union ist oder noch nicht
hat hier auch die europäische petzschner
ist re creation noch nicht
unterschreiben müssen
und ich finde es skandalös dass es
schweizer konzerne die letzten sind die
weltweit quellen und wasser zugänge und
brunnen oder soll alles wirkliche
aufkaufen und privatisieren um daraus
ein geschäft zu machen und gleichzeitig
ist es ein ästhetisches spektakel
er habe das schön
und es ist ja auch schön dass ihr das
gebirge das stein mit dem hegel nichts
anfangen konnte vom wasser ja auch
aufgelöst wird dass diese triebkräfte
des flüssigen die in stein gemeißelten
mythen irgendwann abtragen werden und in
soziale verflüchtigen
das so bleibt
[Musik]
menasse und zweifel sind stolz dass es
eine zunft war der der schweiz titel
heldengeschichte schenkte das china aber
ein ausländern war kann sich robert
menasse nicht verkneifen
doch stephan 24 verwies darauf dass es
der schweizer max frisch war der wählen
teil auf die füße stellt
und das ist für mich die schweiz das ein
anti atom nach ist ja zu zum grund
mythos wird oder werden konnte für eine
geradezu autistischen wieder 73 und er
ist muss es sein
der rebell der gleichzeitig begründet
einen autistischen peters dieses eigene
das nennt man ja kritisch videos das
idiotisch und es gibt ein paar
darstellen das im 18 jahrhundert wilhelm
tell auf einem platz steht als narr
verkleidet und ein hund ist an die
stange von gestern und er verbeugt sich
eben nicht weil us daten den nachspiel
und dieses spielen des narren hat er die
schweizer auch immer wieder übernommen
um diese diese form des ganz
eigensinnigen ist wäre eigentlich eine
tradition an die an dem man selber auch
anschließen könnte und mit erlernen ein
idiot zu sein und die welt eben ganz
eigensinnig und eigen zu sehen
ich glaube jeder künstler ist
dazu muss ich nicht schweizer werden
[Applaus]
unsere herbstreise vor den wahlen
provoziert auch immer wieder die frage
wie hält es die schweiz mit den fremden
in zürich kennt sich robert menasse
schon ein weniger aus letztes jahr ist
er hier max frisch preisträger geworden
in der hoffnung vom österreicher etwas
über die schweiz zu lernen
wir sind der laudatio hieß
hier wohnte legen dafür der russischen
revolution
wir haben die daten die während des
ersten weltkrieges den unsinn des
krieges angeprangert haben haben büchner
der geflohen ist dass deutschland in die
neutrale schweiz wurden lehrern konnte
als arzt und wir haben linien der hier
die revolution vorbereitet hat auch
während des ersten weltkrieges also
alles eigentlich leute die in die
schweiz gegangen sind revolutionäre
aufrührer in einen neutralen ort in eine
art exil und als im exil dann entweder
mit den schriften gewirkt haben oder wie
linie ausgebrochen sind um eine
revolution zu machen was was hält denn
dieses spiegelgasse uns in der schweiz
heute für einen spiegel vor
heute spiegelt sich in der spiegelgasse
eine machtvolle entwicklungstendenz des
kapitalismus nämlich sich und seine
kultur einfach zu mobilisieren dann ist
ja nur noch eine gedenkplatte am haus
anstatt lebendige kultur neben lenin
wohnte der arzt und schriftsteller georg
büchner ein paar hausnummern weiter
das cabrio wollte der französische
aufklärer war nie hier aber sein geist
und vorträgen uhr steht an diesem
geschichtsträchtigen aber hier im
cabaret voltaire wo ja die die das
cabaret voltaire bezog sich auf wollte
er auf die aufklärung wollte ja
irgendwie gegen den krieg dieses nein
zum krieg propagieren im namen der
aufklärung und aus einer aber hugo barra
auf die bühne ging in diesem fach kostüm
und angefangen hat verse zu rezitieren
hat er gemerkt man kann nicht einfach
nur nein zum krieg sagen man kann auch
nicht nur nein zu abendländischen
kultur sagen sondern mussten 1 im
eigenen ich sagen zur sprache zu sprache
in der normalerweise ja auch ein subjekt
herrscht ein hauptwort dass die objekte
die neben wörter in den krieg schickt
mit adjektiven schön verziert und die
verben geben die bewegungs parolen die
front parolen aus man muss also die
sprache verschlagen und ging auf die
bühne und hat dann gesagt sobald die
clean war bei ihm war problem war
rubsamen hobbs amen amen amen dieser
anarchistischer tourismus konnte er nur
hier entstehen sowie die psychoanalyse
mit einiger logik in wien entstehen
musste
es gibt es komischerweise es gibt so so
so fort die titan ist jetzt also herr
vorstellen was man hier entstehen konnte
aber sein allgemeine gültigkeit
[Musik]
wieviel anarchie verträgt die schweiz
heute werden die wahlen in einem monat
etwas dazu aussagen
noch einen abstecher ins zürcher
kunsthaus zu den heroischen gemeinden
von ferdinand hofer das bild zur
schweizer demokratie trägt den titel
einmütigkeit
da hat - einen leichten zweifel wenn
alle gleicher meinung sind ist das noch
demokratie und was passiert mit einem
jahr die hand nicht streckt
unter mozart musik für ein schräges
orchester zeigt ein österreichweites dem
schweizer die schweiz eine ausstellung
die menasse für das kunsthaus zürich mit
kumuliert zum thema europa
und mittendrin die schweiz als sicherer
hafen für große europäer
und diese menschen waren flüchtlinge man
vielleicht länger und die schweizer zu
ihr aufgenommen
und was ich nicht verstehe aber du
kannst mich ja korrigieren vielleicht
sehe ich das falsch und vielleicht weiß
ich zu wenig über die schweiz
aber ich habe den eindruck dass die
schweiz heute ein weiß ob die mehrheit
ist viel zu großer teil der bevölkerung
statt stolz darauf zu sein heute das als
problem sieht ja dass flüchtlinge kommen
oder dass das menschen versuchen in die
schweiz zu kommen ja wegen der vorzüge
die sie hat ja und der sicherheit
diese bietet oder bieten könnte und ich
kann das nicht verstehen wieso anlass zu
stolz wir haben die kultur und den geist
europas gerettet indem wir die
flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben ist james
joyce
[Musik]
autoform ulises und weniger fähig sein
wird so leer wird der romanliteratur
erst recht muss heute unbedingt erklären
also gemacht wird mussolini der war ja
auch hier war das noch an nach ist oder
naja war damals sozialist satellit er
noch gab es ist sondern sondern wirklich
sozialist und hat eine rede gehalten und
zürich aber was ich arthur schnitzler
also bitte immer so viel dass er über
die seelischen abgründe der menschen
lernen kann
thomas mann ja der sich schreibend zum
demokraten selbst erzogen hat das ist ja
ganz auf ganz exemplarisch an typische
europäische biografie
wer zeigt jetzt wem was die schweiz
ausmacht
im odeon dem wiener café in zürich lag
früher die ganze welt presse auf heute
einzig tages anzeiger
1 z 2 will wissen wie unsere direkte
demokratie bei menasse ankommt das
einzige was mir immer wieder irritiert
in der schweiz haben schon von
demokratie werden was mir immer wieder
irritiert ist
dieser fetisch der direkten demokratie
referent um das ein rechtszustand
auszuhebeln versucht nämlich die
freizügigkeit die vertraglich mit der
europäischen union und der schweiz
garantiert ist ja das ist auch wachs ist
diese referendum produziere vertrags
burg selbst wer das anders sieht muss
anerkennen dass wir auch so im
europäischen österreich wahrgenommen
werden
wie sehen sie denn dieses europäische
die zürcher zeitung produziert nicht nur
das kollektive bewusstsein der schweizer
selbst die zürcher zeitung prägte auch
das schweiz bild im ausnahmsweise europa
auch menasses bild von der schweiz ist
durch die nz geprägt seit 40 jahren
hatte das weltbad abonniert besuch in
der redaktion
wenn erstes buch die vertreibung aus der
hölle ist einzeltäter redakteur andreas
brey und stein wo bekannt da haben wir
über einen haben sie eine ganze spalte
geschrieben über einen radikalen fehler
auf seite 2 117 immens und immer gedacht
ein come at kalisch grammatikalische
fehler auf einem 500 seiten romana und
kann ich mich gar nicht und dann hat die
dudenredaktion bei der suhrkamp-verlag
ganz aufgeregt war
hat man von der ton in der redaktion die
bestätigung bekommen es war kein
grammatikalische fehler sondern nur in
der schweiz umgebracht
wie auch immer eine ganze seite
buchbesprechung in grenze zeit kam ein
ritterschlag für - reich im newsroom wie
die zeitung von morgen zusammengestellt
in jedem amerikanischen film wo man
einen newsroom fehlt ist die blanke
hektik und ist es jetzt spezifisch
schweizerisch dass der schweizer kein
talent hat hektisch zu sein
oder ist es einfach ist allgemein
moderner die alte tante im neuen kleid